It had to do with the trajectory of our lives. You were, we were kind of making. Oh, I do vaguely recall this. We were, we were making predictions on, you know, where we would be. I don't, I don't remember what I predicted. Talking about how we're not going to talk about it. Now we're going to talk about it. So, but like, we're not talking about dating.
这与我们人生的轨迹有关。你当时，我们当时好像在做。哦，我隐约记得这件事。我们当时在预测，你知道，我们未来会在哪里。我不记得我预测了什么。谈论我们不打算谈论它。现在我们要谈论它了。所以，但是，我们不是在谈论约会。
That was not the question. We didn't, you didn't ask me who's better at dating. You asked, who do you think is going to get married and kids first or just married first. It's not a dating podcast in general, but episode 200 is mostly a dating and forecasting podcast. Do you talk about tech at any point in this episode? No, I think literally the intro will be welcome to episode 200 of ADSP the podcast. Feel free to skip this if you're only here for the tech content. Okay, fair enough.
那不是问题所在。你没有，你没有问我谁更擅长约会。你问的是，你认为谁会先结婚生子，或者只是先结婚。这总体上不是一个约会播客，但第200集主要是一个约会和预测播客。你在这集节目中任何时候谈论过技术吗？不，我想开场白字面上会是欢迎收听ADSP播客第200集。如果你只是为了技术内容而来，请随意跳过这一段。好吧，有道理。
Welcome to ADSP the podcast episode 200, recorded on all of August 26, 2024, March 27, 2022, and September 18th and 19th, 2024. My name is Connor. And today with my co-host Bryce and our two partners, Ramona and Shima. We revisit a conversation from 2.5 years ago. Which brings us to episode 200, folks. Except it's not going to be 200. I think we're going to make this. I think what we're going to do is we're going to make this episode 201 and we're going to skip episode 200 for later. Because
欢迎收听ADSP播客第200集，录制于2024年8月26日、2022年3月27日以及2024年9月18日和19日。我是Connor。今天和我的联合主持人Bryce以及我们的两位合伙人Ramona和Shima在一起。我们重温了2.5年前的一次对话。这把我们带到了第200集，各位。除了它不会是第200集。我想我们要把它做成。我想我们要做的就是把它做成第201集，然后把第200集留到以后。因为
I don't think we're ready for episode 200. At the end of, let's go and take a gander, folks. And maybe we'll end up talking about... I don't know what's go and take a gander, folks. And maybe we'll end up talking about. I don't know what's in store for me right now, but. Nothing's in store.
我不认为我们准备好做第200集了。在……结束时，让我们去看看吧，各位。也许我们最终会谈论……我不知道……让我们去看看吧，各位。也许我们最终会谈论。我不知道现在有什么在等着我，但是。什么都没有等着。
Nothing's in store. So we recorded episodes 72 and, or did we actually record, was it 72, 71? I feel like it's a real rug pull to everybody's going to be anticipating episode 200. No, but they don't remember. Folks don't remember. So episode 71 and 72 were recorded on March 27th, 2022, which today it is August 26th, 2024. So that was almost two and a half years ago. We have been recording for almost four years now.
什么都没有等着。所以我们录制了第72集，或者我们真的录制了，是72集还是71集？我觉得这对每个人来说都是一个真正的打击，因为大家都在期待第200集。不，但他们不记得了。大家不记得了。所以第71集和第72集是在2022年3月27日录制的，而今天是2024年8月26日。所以那是将近两年半前的事了。我们现在已经录制了快四年了。
November, what was it? November, let's go get, I don't actually know when the, well actually we can just click on episode zero. Our first episode aired on November 20th, 2020. We recorded it on November 14th of 2020. So it's August. We're two months short of four years. And I think we maybe have referenced this kind of special thing a couple times on random episodes. But at the end of that recording on March 27th of 2022,
十一月，是什么时候？十一月，让我们去拿，我其实不知道什么时候，好吧，其实我们可以直接点击第零集。我们的第一集是在2020年11月20日播出的。我们是在2020年11月14日录制的。所以现在是八月。我们离四年还差两个月。我想我们可能在随机的几集里提到过这种特殊的事情。但在2022年3月27日那次录音结束时，
two and a half years ago, just about, which ended up being episode 71 and 72, they were entitled, episode 71 was entitled APL Cobol Basic and More. And then episode 72 was called the C++ Algorithm Family Feud, which clearly would have been.
大约两年半前，最终成为了第71集和第72集，它们的标题是，第71集的标题是《APL、Cobol、Basic及更多》。然后第72集叫《C++算法家族纷争》，这显然会是……
Oh, yeah, I remember. We ended up talking about, I think, the different ways to implement a problem based on the algorithms in the show notes. The problem was determining. I think that was a quiz. It was a quiz. And I don't think I did well. Well, no, it was a was a quiz in that like name the ways you can implement finding the top two values in a list of integers
哦，是的，我记得。我们最终谈论的是，我想，基于节目笔记中的算法实现问题的不同方法。问题是确定。我想那是一个测验。那是一个测验。而且我不认为我做得很好。好吧，不，那是一个测验，就像列出你可以实现查找整数列表中前两个值的方法一样
in that I asked you questions that had answers well it's not exactly a quiz it was family feud so you know top seven answers on the board and anyways at the end of that recording there was 10 to 20 minutes of content that we were still recording for.
我问了你一些有答案的问题，好吧，这不完全是一个测验，它是《家族纷争》，所以你知道，板上的前七个答案，总之在录音结束时，还有10到20分钟的内容我们还在录制。
I mean, there was actually, I think, an hour, an hour and a half of stuff we recorded. But only 10 to 20 minutes of it is airable. And in that conversation, you have, I mean, I mentioned this to you, I think, 10, not 10 days, but like maybe 10 episodes. I don't know. Probably when you were in Toronto a month ago. Yeah. not 10 days, but like maybe 10 episodes. I don't know. Probably when you were in Toronto a month ago and you had zero recollection of having this conversation and what the contents of the conversation was. And in that conversation, you said, well, maybe we'll revisit this conversation at episode 200. But I think, I think we're just going to have to leave this as a teaser. Will it be episode 250 or will it be episode 300? Maybe episode 250 is good because we want to do something special. We can't defer episode 200 to be episode 300. We'd have to defer it to be... Wait, wait, wait. What was the thing? What was the thing that I said we would defer?
我的意思是，实际上，我想，我们录制了一个小时，一个半小时的内容。但只有10到20分钟是可以播出的。在那次对话中，你，我的意思是，我向你提到了这一点，我想，10天，不是10天，而是大概10集左右。我不知道。可能是在你一个月前在多伦多的时候。是的。不是10天，而是大概10集左右。我不知道。可能是在你一个月前在多伦多的时候，你对这次对话以及对话的内容完全没有记忆。在那次对话中，你说，好吧，也许我们会在第200集重温这次对话。但我认为，我认为我们只能把它作为一个预告。它会是第250集还是第300集？也许第250集不错，因为我们想做点特别的事情。我们不能把第200集推迟到第300集。我们得把它推迟到……等等，等等，等等。那件事是什么？我说我们要推迟的那件事是什么？
Well, if I mention it, then we have to end up talking about it. Well, let's do it but then the idea was and i haven't done the legwork for this is that i was gonna we were gonna listen to the you know 10 to 15 minutes and then we were gonna respond okay but i don't i don't have that stuff i mean i do have it on my computer over here but i mean i can redact this for the listener connor i I will make you a deal. I will make you a deal. All right.
好吧，如果我提到了它，那么我们最终就得谈论它。好吧，我们做吧，但当时的想法是——我还没有做这方面的准备工作——我打算，我们要听那10到15分钟的内容，然后我们要做出回应。好吧，但我没有那些东西，我的意思是，我电脑里确实有，但我可以为听众删减这些内容。Connor，我跟你做个交易。我跟你做个交易。好吧。
If you get that content ready tonight, I will, on the first night of my vacation, I will listen and record a response. No, I think, well, here, let me, so this is, I'm trying to figure out when. You got to give me a hint. You got to give me a hint. It had to do with the trajectory Of our lives I do vaguely recall this We were making predictions On where we would be
如果你今晚准备好那些内容，我会在我假期的第一天晚上听并录制回应。不，我想，好吧，让我，所以这是，我正在试图弄清楚什么时候。你得给我个提示。你得给我个提示。这与我们人生的轨迹有关。我隐约记得这件事。我们当时在做预测，关于我们未来会在哪里。
I don't remember what I predicted Yeah so Episode 250 I mean unsurprisingly Is gonna be a year from now. So, yeah, we have an off by two based on this spreadsheet. I think I do now recall the predictions. I think I do now recall.
我不记得我预测了什么。是的，所以第250集，我的意思是，不出所料，将是一年之后。所以，是的，根据这个电子表格，我们有一个偏差为二的情况。我想我现在确实回想起那些预测了。我想我现在确实回想起来了。
But I think we're going to have to. I should what? You should put it together and send it to me tonight so that I can record something. A response from Miami. Oh, so we can just record individually? That's what you want to do? Yeah, yeah, yeah. I guess I could try and do that.
但我认为我们必须。我应该什么？你应该把它整理好今晚发给我，这样我就可以录制一些东西。来自迈阿密的回应。哦，所以我们可以单独录制？这就是你想做的？是的，是的，是的。我想我可以试着那样做。
Yeah, yeah. We'll see how it goes. Got to deliver for the listener. We got to deliver for the listener. All right, wait. So let me do the math on this then. So episode 198 is going to be out on – so this would mean episode 200 is going to air on September 20th. You'll be, I think, in Italy at that point in time. No, no, I'll be back.
是的，是的。我们看看进展如何。必须为听众提供内容。我们必须为听众提供内容。好吧，等等。所以让我算算这个。所以第198集将在——所以这意味着第200集将在9月20日播出。我想那时你会在意大利。不，不，我会回来的。
I'm back on the 17th. Wait, when am I going to Italy? Am I going to Italy? Do I not know about going to Italy? Were you going to Italy? Do I not know about going to Italy? Were you going to Italy? I thought you were. Oh, maybe that was last year you went. Didn't you go to Italy in September at some point?
我17号回来。等等，我什么时候去意大利？我要去意大利吗？我不知道我要去意大利吗？你要去意大利吗？我不知道我要去意大利吗？你要去意大利吗？我以为你要去。哦，也许那是你去年去的。你不是在九月的某个时候去了意大利吗？
Yeah, I did. That was last year. Okay. I would conflate it. I mean, Connor, you have to tell me if I'm supposed to be in a certain country. You know, when your co-host travels as much as you do, you conflate the months of the year and the countries that you're going to be in. So anyways, September 20th is supposedly when the listener is listening to this.
是的，我去了。那是去年。好吧。我会把它搞混的。我的意思是，Connor，如果你希望我在某个国家，你必须告诉我。你知道，当你的联合主持人像你一样经常旅行时，你会把一年中的月份和你将要去的国家搞混。所以总之，9月20日据说是听众收听这一集的时间。
They just heard us talk for 10 to 15 minutes about how we weren't going to air episode 20. But at some point before... Episode 200. Oh, yeah. Episode 200. but at some point before episode 200 oh yeah episode 200 it's maybe it won't be tonight but at some point when bryce is on vacation you got you got to do it tonight because i'm going to be in a cruise ship i'm going to have like no internet connectivity for the first seven days you got to do it tonight well we got we've got three weeks though so you you you got it come on you got it you can't leave the people hanging you can't leave the
他们刚刚听我们谈了10到15分钟关于我们不打算播出第20集。但在某个时候之前……第200集。哦，是的。第200集。但在第200集之前的某个时候，哦，是的，第200集，也许不是今晚，但在Bryce度假时的某个时候，你今晚必须做，因为我会在游轮上，前七天我几乎没有互联网连接，你今晚必须做。好吧，我们还有三周时间，所以你，你，你做得到的，来吧，你做得到的，你不能让大家悬着，你不能让
people hanging they're not hanging they're gonna get it on september 20th regardless of when you record oh oh you're gonna you're gonna put you're gonna use this for for episode 200 you're gonna i mean episode 200 is i mean the numbered episode 200 if we release an episode 200, will be on September 20th, no matter what. Yeah. Because we've got... Get Shima over here so I can negotiate with her to let you spend your evening doing this. She's out of the thing right now. So I really have no excuse why I couldn't do it.
大家悬着，他们不会悬着的，无论你什么时候录制，他们都会在9月20日得到它。哦，哦，你要，你要把这个用于第200集，你要，我的意思是第200集是，我的意思是编号为200的那一集，如果我们发布第200集，无论如何都会在9月20日。是的。因为我们有……让Shima过来，这样我可以和她商量，让她让你花晚上时间做这个。她现在不在那儿。所以我真的没有理由说我为什么不能做。
Yeah, you get it. Send it over. All right. We will end our recording I guess we're going to record separate follow ups we are we'll do I guess a little phone tag
是的，你做得到。发过来吧。好吧。我想我们要结束录音了，我们要录制单独的后续内容，是的，我想我们会玩一点电话游戏
or maybe we won't even do phone tag we'll just do two separate tracks Bryce won't hear mine but I'll get to hear his and then I'll put it together and the listener can be entertained or not entertained. Maybe they didn't even make it this far into episode 200 because we've just been talking about how we're not going to talk about it. Now we're going to talk about it.
或者也许我们甚至不会玩电话游戏，我们只会做两个单独的轨道，Bryce听不到我的，但我能听到他的，然后我会把它拼在一起，听众可能会觉得有趣，也可能不会。也许他们甚至没有坚持听到第200集的这一部分，因为我们一直在谈论我们不打算谈论它。现在我们要谈论它了。
So. All right. Hopefully you enjoyed the rotate episode. If you didn't enjoy episode 200, we apologize. Yeah. If you've got a if you've got a if you've got a you got it if you got a parallel rotate algorithm call me like a year ago i would have just gone and spent like a month of my life just like cutting up myself but uh but i don't i don't have time for that anymore so somebody else go do the work bring bring me
所以。好吧。希望你喜欢这个旋转集。如果你不喜欢第200集，我们道歉。是的。如果你有，如果你有，如果你有，如果你有一个并行旋转算法，一年前打电话给我，我可能就会花我生命中的一个月时间自己去切分它，但是，但我没有时间做那个了，所以让别人去做这项工作，带给我
bring me a high performance cuda rotate algorithm god what are we gonna to do when we have children? I don't know. I don't know. I'm getting old, man. Yeah, we are getting old. We are getting old. So the probability that that's going to end up happening decreases as every day goes by. All right, on that note.
带给我一个高性能的CUDA旋转算法，天哪，当我们有了孩子后我们要怎么办？我不知道。我不知道。我老了，伙计。是的，我们正在变老。我们正在变老。所以这种情况发生的概率随着每一天的过去而降低。好吧，说到这里。
You're like 30. You're still. all right on that note you're like 30 you're like 30 you've still there i'm sure i'm like i i hope that we have some if you've made it this far in the podcast we're just really gonna open up right now we probably have some some female listeners who are listening to connor say that oh no he's hit 30 and like now he's his prospects for having children are like done and they're probably not amused i didn't say that they're gone like you realize that as a guy like you you could have children like it is like another 20 years it is gender agnostic from the i'm a former statistician and actuary, from a statistical point of view, every day that passes by, regardless of what, actually, that's maybe not true.
你才30岁左右。你仍然。好吧，说到这里，你才30岁左右，你才30岁左右，你仍然在那里，我确信，我像，我希望我们有一些，如果你已经听到播客的这一部分，我们现在真的要敞开心扉了，我们可能有一些女性听众正在听Connor说，哦不，他已经30岁了，现在他生孩子的希望已经完了，她们可能觉得不好笑。我没说它们没了，就像你意识到作为一个男人，你可以生孩子，就像还有20年，从我是一个前统计学家和精算师的角度来看，从统计学的角度来看，每一天过去，无论什么，其实，那可能不是真的。
Because, like, it's like the mortality curve of drivers is that there's actually, like, an uptick at some point, you know, because of, you know, people drive recklessly in their, like, early 20s. So, like, maybe, you know, past a certain point. Actually, not so. On average, average though i would say on average because that's the thing is if you're going through some career that like takes a lot of work maybe you become more eligible once that calms down and you you know you finish studying for something so like maybe maybe there are some curves for some individuals where like actually later into certain years the the probability goes up. But I think it's downhill for now from here on out for me. I don't think we're putting this in the episode. Your 30s is a period of time when people have kids these days,
因为，就像，司机的死亡曲线是，实际上在某个点有一个上升，你知道，因为，你知道，人们在20岁出头时开车鲁莽。所以，也许，你知道，过了某个点。其实并非如此。平均而言，平均来说，我会说平均而言，因为这就是问题所在，如果你正在经历某种需要大量工作的职业，也许一旦那平静下来，你（你知道）完成了某项学习，你就会变得更有资格，所以也许，也许对某些个人来说有一些曲线，实际上在某些年份之后，概率会上升。但我认为对我来说，从现在开始就是下坡路了。我不认为我们会把这个放进这一集里。30多岁是人们这些天生孩子的时期，
with the exception of a few of our friends who wisely planned to have their children when they were younger so that they'll now be able to retire uh earlier answer me this mr mr lullback um how quickly do you think you go from being single to having kids because i may be 31 uh i don't and you're saying that's when people start having kids it's not like you go to the dating apps you swipe right and then and then two days later, you're having kids. I don't want to answer that question because I don't want to incriminate myself. I'll give you my answer. I feel like at our age, like two to three years, like you date for one year.
除了我们少数几个明智地计划在年轻时生孩子的朋友，这样他们现在就能更早退休。回答我这个问题，Lullback先生，你认为你从单身到有孩子需要多快？因为我可能31岁，我不知道，你说那是人们开始生孩子的年龄，这不像你上约会软件，你向右滑，然后两天后，你就有了孩子。我不想回答那个问题，因为我不想自证其罪。我会给你我的答案。我觉得在我们这个年纪，两到三年，比如你约会一年。
Then you get engaged. year then you like you get engaged and then you get married and then there's like one or two years this is gonna man this is gonna be so awesome because i'm gonna like i might try and find a way to put this in here there's a lot of editing that'll maybe i'll like save on to it for a later episode or some like bonus episode this and like in three years from now check in i'm gonna revise my i'm gonna revise my answer to like three to four years i'm gonna this is what it's gonna end up the bryce life roadmap on the bryce five-year life roadmap in five years i'll have i'll be married and have children see see i made i made a mistake in that you asked me a question and I originally, I answered by giving you like a timeline for execution.
然后你订婚。一年，然后你订婚，然后你结婚，然后有一到两年，这会，伙计，这会非常棒，因为我会，我可能会想办法把它放进去，有很多剪辑，也许我会把它留到以后的一集或者某个奖励集里，然后在三年后检查一下，我会修改我的，我会把我的答案修改为三到四年，我会，这就是最终的结果，Bryce人生路线图，在Bryce五年人生路线图中，五年后我会结婚并有孩子，看，看，我犯了一个错误，你问了我一个问题，我最初，我通过给你一个执行时间表来回答。
And that was the wrong answer. Then I adjusted to the correct answer, which is, you know, the executive producer answer of the goal is in five years married with children. And I'll figure out the details of how i get there later obviously if it's four years from now then i'm like and i'm not married and don't have children then the timetable will be a little bit accelerated i see i see that's a lot i think that's consistent with my point of view too is it's like, you know, you've got this sort of roadmap, but like we're approaching the point where like, if in the next couple of years, blah, blah, blah,
那是错误的答案。然后我调整为正确的答案，也就是，你知道，执行制片人的答案，目标是五年内结婚生子。我会稍后再弄清楚我如何到达那里的细节，显然如果那是四年后，然后我像，我还没有结婚也没有孩子，那么时间表会稍微加快一点。我明白了，我明白了，我认为这与我的观点也是一致的，就像，你知道，你有这种路线图，但我们正在接近那个点，如果未来几年内，等等，等等，
yeah, that road is like, obviously. My mom had me when she was 35. I've got friends who've... That's the thing. I know you can get married and have kids at like 40 and stuff, or even, you know, kids comes a little bit questionable into your 40s and whatnot. But like, there's always the option to adopt and you can still
是的，那条路显然是。我妈妈35岁时生了我。我有朋友……这就是问题所在。我知道你可以在40岁左右结婚生子，甚至，你知道，孩子在40多岁时有点问题等等。但总是可以选择领养，你仍然可以
have a family. And I'm not saying that it's impossible. I'm just saying that as statistically, you know, I don't know which one of us is going to be married first. Oh, this'll be a whole, we can just keep chatting. This'll be a whole bonus episode. If you stick around until like episode you know 150 or 200 or something um probably you probably why me why do you think me
拥有一个家庭。我不是说这不可能。我只是说从统计学上讲，你知道，我不知道我们俩谁会先结婚。哦，这会是一个完整的，我们可以继续聊天。这会是一个完整的奖励集。如果你坚持听到第150集或200集左右，嗯，可能你，可能为什么是我，你为什么认为是我
because i just i don't know i think you're like you're better at this kind of stuff you know you're more charismatic you weren't no no you definitely have to be better at dating than i am but like we're not talking about dating that was not the question we didn't you didn't ask me who's better at dating you asked who do you think is gonna get was it married and kids first or just married first yeah i think it yeah i think you are better at accomplishing goals that you set for yourself i'm not saying that i'm bad at that. My mother very much wants grandchildren, but she never nags me about it.
因为我只是，我不知道，我认为你，你更擅长这类事情，你知道，你更有魅力，你不是，不，不，你绝对必须比我更擅长约会，但我们不是在谈论约会。那不是问题所在。你没有，你没有问我谁更擅长约会，你问的是你认为谁会先，是结婚生子还是先结婚。是的，我想，是的，我想你更擅长完成你为自己设定的目标，我不是说我不擅长那个。我母亲非常想要孙子，但她从不为此唠叨我。
And I asked her a few years ago, why? And she tells me, you know, kid, after you dropped out of school and went like, you know, moved to Louisiana and just sort of forged your own path to getting a career. Louisiana and just sort of forged your own path to getting a career, I realized that like there was no point anymore trying to like provide you with guidance or encouragement that you were just going to do your own things and that like once you set your mind to something, you would make it happen. And I always just assumed that once you set your mind on the goal of like getting
几年前我问她，为什么？她告诉我，你知道，孩子，在你辍学并去，你知道，搬到路易斯安那州并以某种方式开辟了你自己的职业道路之后。路易斯安那州并以某种方式开辟了你自己的职业道路，我意识到，再试图为你提供指导或鼓励已经没有意义了，你只会做你自己的事情，一旦你下定决心做某事，你就会让它发生。我一直认为，一旦你下定决心要
married and having children, that you would approach it with the same intensity that you do everything else in life, and that there would be spreadsheets and charts and planning, and that you'd have all of it taken care of. She's not wrong. That is a perfect articulation of exactly what I was trying to say. I'm not saying I'm bad at dating. I'm not saying I think I'll be single for the rest of my life i'm just saying in terms of you know who's gonna get to the marriage finish line and
结婚生子，你就会以你对待生活中其他一切事情的同样强度去对待它，会有电子表格、图表和计划，你会把这一切都处理好。她说得没错。那是我试图表达的完美阐述。我不是说我不擅长约会。我不是说我认为我余生都会单身，我只是说，你知道，谁会先到达结婚终点线和
kids finish line first i just think that uh you are a better uh goal accomplisher and you've put that on your you put that on the roadmap and you know it's uh that means it's uh it's gg for anyone that's betting against you right now um anyways episode 72 over so how are i mean we can stop recording at this point hard things this is gold we'll use this one all right maybe we'll save this till um what is a thousand what is a thousand episodes that's like 20 years by episode 200 that gives me like 130 weeks or so that's like we're at 72 100 i i'm fairly confident i'll be engaged by the time we get to episode 200 uh this so this is a fun game predicting oh man i think that's the thing is like you're you're you're like i'm gonna do it
孩子终点线，我只是认为，你是一个更好的目标实现者，你已经把它放在了你的路线图上，你知道，这，这意味着，这是，这对任何现在赌你输的人来说都是GG。嗯，总之，第72集结束了，所以我们怎么，我的意思是我们可以此时停止录音，困难的事情，这是金子，我们会用这一集。好吧，也许我们会把它留到，嗯，什么是1000，什么是1000集，那大约是20年，到第200集，那给了我大约130周左右，那就像我们现在在72，100，我相当自信到我们到达第200集时我会订婚，嗯，这，这是一个有趣的预测游戏，哦天哪，我想这就是问题所在，就像你，你就像，我要做它
episode 200 definitely engaged maybe married i like i think about it and i'm just like uh i'm gonna be alone for the rest of my life you gotta you gotta have confidence man not that i really believe that. Yeah, I just don't know. I am debating. Well, I think I've ruled out inviting the Polish girl to, whose name is Ramona, inviting her to Family Passover because I like that girl and I'm fairly certain that if she came to Family Passover, she would never want to talk to me again
第200集绝对订婚，也许结婚，我喜欢，我想到它，我只是像，呃，我余生都要一个人过了。你得，你得有信心，伙计，并不是我真的相信那个。是的，我只是不知道。我正在辩论。好吧，我想我已经排除了邀请那个波兰女孩，名字叫Ramona，邀请她参加家庭逾越节，因为我喜欢那个女孩，而且我相当确定如果她来参加家庭逾越节，她就再也不想和我说话了
because my family is nuts. Testing, testing, testing. Well, I am here with the Polish girl. I was wondering, did we record that before or after I started dating Ramona? But given that I talk about the Polish girl whose name is Ramona, it must have been afterwards. But we were just laughing at the part about that I didn't want to invite her to family Passover. Because I was afraid that if I exposed her to my family that she wouldn't want to have anything to do with me.
因为我的家人很疯狂。测试，测试，测试。好吧，我和那个波兰女孩在一起。我在想，我们是在我开始和Ramona约会之前还是之后录制的？但鉴于我谈论的是那个名字叫Ramona的波兰女孩，那一定是在之后。但我们刚才在笑关于我不想邀请她参加家庭逾越节的那部分。因为我担心如果我让她接触我的家人，她就不会想和我有什么瓜葛了。
And now, honey, do you have a choice to be whether or not you're exposed to my family? I do not. Yeah, she does not. And yeah, I mean, I guess you beat me to the punch because you're now engaged. But I will note that I am still dating the same person that I was dating when we recorded that. So that's something, right? Yeah? Honey, should we get engaged and married before Connor just to spite him? I suppose that's probably not a good basis for getting married. But we're very excited about your wedding, which I guess is going to be sometime next year.
现在，亲爱的，你还有选择是否接触我的家人的余地吗？我没有。是的，她没有。而且是的，我的意思是，我想你抢先了一步，因为你现在订婚了。但我会指出，我仍然在和我们录制那集时约会的同一个人约会。所以那也是一回事，对吧？是吗？亲爱的，我们应该在Connor之前订婚结婚来气他吗？我想那可能不是结婚的好基础。但我们对你们的婚礼感到非常兴奋，我想那大概会在明年某个时候。
We're looking forward to going to Mexico. Yeah, yeah. Not that all the listeners are invited, so we're not going to say where in Mexico. But I guess now it's just a race to who has children first. So, yeah, Connor, you're going to have to pop a few out there. Oh, man. Gosh, it's funny that we were recording that when we were 30 and we were lamenting how old we feel because during the trip that Ramona and I were just on, well, honey, what did you find? I found some gray hair on Bryce's head.
我们期待着去墨西哥。是的，是的。并不是所有的听众都被邀请了，所以我们不会说在墨西哥的哪里。但我想现在这只是一场谁先有孩子的比赛。所以，是的，Connor，你得生几个出来。哦，天哪。天哪，真有趣，我们在30岁时录制那集，我们还在哀叹我们感觉自己有多老，因为在Ramona和我刚去的旅行中，嗯，亲爱的，你发现了什么？我在Bryce的头上发现了一些白头发。
Now, I think the gray hair is fake news. She did take pictures, though, so it is a little bit hard to deny. But, you know, my hair is so important to my identity because it's great and amazing and my most attractive feature. And I was deeply distraught about it. Like, I had moments of existential dread. And, boy, do I wish I could go back to being 30 when I could like sleep through the night and when things didn't randomly ink. And I'm sure all of our
现在，我认为白头发是假新闻。不过她确实拍了照片，所以确实有点难以否认。但是，你知道，我的头发对我的身份非常重要，因为它是很棒的，令人惊叹的，是我最有吸引力的特征。我对此深感不安。就像，我有过存在主义恐惧的时刻。而且，天哪，我真希望我能回到30岁，那时我可以像睡过整晚，那时事情不会随机地……而且我确信我们所有的
listeners who are, you know, a good bit older than us are just thinking like, ah, these kids, they have no idea. But yeah, it's funny that we thought we were old when we were, like, 30 and 31. Do you feel old, honey? Sometimes. You're not old. You're beautiful and youthful. I feel old, though. Oh, boy.
听众，你知道，比我们大不少，只是在想，啊，这些孩子，他们根本不知道。但是的，很有趣，我们以为我们老了，当我们，就像，30岁和31岁时。你觉得老吗，亲爱的？有时。你不老。你美丽而年轻。但我感觉老了。哦，天哪。
So by what episode do you think we'll be married, honey? I don't know. 300 maybe? What is marriage? Marriage is you get a big fancy ring. You can't get that without signing a paper? I suppose. I suppose technically. We could be a modern couple married differently.
所以你认为我们会在哪一集结婚，亲爱的？我不知道。300集也许？什么是婚姻？婚姻是你得到一枚昂贵的大戒指。没有签署文件你就不能得到那个？我想是吧。我想从技术上讲。我们可以是一对以不同方式结婚的现代夫妇。
I mean, technically we do reside together, um, and have resided together for a long period of time. So does that mean I deserve a ring? I mean, I think you deserve a ring. Oh, man. Well, I guess, Connor, it'll be interesting to see where we are by, like, episode 400. Maybe we'll both be married and have children. Yeah, yeah, I'd be interested what your timetable for that is for the kids part is
我的意思是，从技术上讲我们确实住在一起，嗯，并且已经住在一起很长一段时间了。所以那意味着我应该得到一枚戒指吗？我的意思是，我认为你应该得到一枚戒指。哦，天哪。好吧，我想，Connor，看看我们在，比如，第400集时会在哪里会很有趣。也许我们俩都结婚并有了孩子。是的，是的，我会对你生孩子的时间表感兴趣
has the timetable uh uh adjusted any from uh from what you predicted uh what it must have been two or three years ago anyways I'm sure that this episode is gonna be very interesting all right well uh uh I'm going to send you over this recording so that you can put together this episode. And I hope to talk to you soon. We've been away for like three weeks. We were in the Galapagos and then Ecuador. And we saw a lot of birds in the Galapagos. It was amazing.
时间表，嗯，嗯，是否从，从你预测的，嗯，一定是在两三年前调整过？总之，我相信这一集会非常有趣。好吧，嗯，嗯，我要把这段录音发给你，这样你就可以整理这一集了。我希望很快能和你谈谈。我们已经离开大约三周了。我们在加拉帕戈斯群岛，然后是厄瓜多尔。我们在加拉帕戈斯群岛看到了很多鸟。太棒了。
And we know how much you love birds. And we know that you're thinking about going to the Galapagos. It was amazing. And we know how much you love birds. And we know that you're thinking about going to the Galapagos for your honeymoon. And we highly recommend it. Yeah? Yes, we do. And make sure you cut me out from the podcast. All right. You heard it from Ramona.
而且我们知道你有多喜欢鸟。而且我们知道你在考虑去加拉帕戈斯群岛。太棒了。而且我们知道你有多喜欢鸟。而且我们知道你在考虑去加拉帕戈斯群岛度蜜月。我们强烈推荐它。是吗？是的，我们推荐。而且确保你把我从播客中剪掉。好吧。你从Ramona那里听到了。
But, yeah, you should definitely, definitely go to the Galapagos. Oh, and I had a great time at NDC Tech Town. Great little conference. I gave my talk on C++ Horizons, and I updated the part of the talk about reflection. And I'm now so excited about reflection that i think i'm going to make a whole talk dedicated just to reflection um because uh it is just a really cool feature and um and going through and updating the talk um all the examples became like 10x better
但是，是的，你绝对，绝对应该去加拉帕戈斯群岛。哦，我在NDC Tech Town玩得很开心。很棒的小会议。我做了关于C++ Horizons的演讲，我更新了演讲中关于反射的部分。我现在对反射感到非常兴奋，以至于我想做一个专门针对反射的完整演讲，嗯，因为，嗯，它确实是一个非常酷的功能，而且，嗯，在更新演讲的过程中，嗯，所有的例子都变得像10倍更好
with some of the new uh refin to reflection, like token sequences. And now I'm just very convinced that it's the right model for C++. Anyways, hope to hear from you soon, buddy. And again, congratulations on your engagement. Bye. All right, folks. It's episode 200, September 19th. Less than, I'm pretty sure, it's almost exactly 12 hours away from when this episode will be releasing.
随着一些新的，嗯，对反射的改进，比如标记序列。现在我非常确信它是C++的正确模型。总之，希望很快能收到你的消息，伙计。再次祝贺你的订婚。再见。好吧，各位。这是第200集，9月19日。距离这一集发布的时间，我非常确定，几乎正好还有12个小时。
You just heard from Bryce and Ramona. And if that's the case, it's only fair that I bring on my beautiful fiance, Shima. But we're going to throw back because it's episode 200. The first thing, I guess not the first thing. The first thing you're hearing is my voice. The next thing you're going to hear, though, is guess what, folks? A lime. Bubbly.
你刚刚听到了Bryce和Ramona的声音。如果是这样的话，我带上我美丽的未婚妻Shima也是公平的。但我们要回顾一下，因为这是第200集。第一件事，我想不是第一件事。你听到的第一件事是我的声音。不过，接下来你要听到的，猜猜是什么，各位？青柠。气泡水。
Let's go. Shima's taking the first sip. Does it taste glorious? she gave me a thumbs up say hi hello and shima has listened to parts two and parts three which is the two and a half years ago recording from post episode 71 and 72 and she listened to what Bryce and Ramona had to say. So I am just going to turn the mic over to Shima, and she's going to do all the heavy lifting for the remaining 5 to 10 minutes of this episode.
开始吧。Shima喝了第一口。味道好吗？她给了我一个大拇指，说嗨，你好，Shima听了第二部分和第三部分，也就是两年半前录制的第71集和第72集之后的内容，她听了Bryce和Ramona要说的话。所以我只是要把麦克风交给Shima，她将承担这一集剩余5到10分钟的所有繁重工作。
Okay, sure, I can do that. So I have some thoughts. So my first thought was just how sweet you sounded when I listened back to that video. I was thinking about sweet you sounded when i listened back to that video i was thinking about how you connor challenge everyone's gender stereotypes because you are so looking forward to having a wedding getting married having kids which i thought was so sweet just warmed my heart very romantic guy and i felt very lucky to listen to that continue continue this is lovely okay well it's so hard right now the next thing
好的，当然，我可以那样做。所以我有一些想法。所以我的第一个想法就是当你回听那个视频时，你的声音听起来有多甜。我在想当你回听那个视频时，你的声音听起来有多甜，我在想你Connor是如何挑战每个人的性别刻板印象的，因为你非常期待举办婚礼、结婚、生孩子，我觉得这太甜了，温暖了我的心，非常浪漫的家伙，我觉得能听到那个非常幸运，继续，继续，这很可爱，好的，好吧，现在太难了，下一件事
i'm going to say is to disagree with you about one of the things you said which is that fertility is gender agnostic so obviously as you know i'm a physician and i'm passionate about many things but one of those things is female age-related infertility and so strongly disagree demonstrably false that male infertility equals female infertility as people age. Do you want to challenge that and go into further details or will you accept that as fact? I will accept that as fact. I cannot believe you called age-related infertility gender agnostic.
我要说的是不同意你关于你所说的一件事，那就是生育能力与性别无关，所以显然如你所知，我是一名医生，我对很多事情充满热情，但其中之一是女性年龄相关的生育能力下降，所以强烈不同意，男性生育能力等于女性生育能力随着年龄增长是明显错误的。你想挑战这一点并深入细节，还是你会接受它作为事实？我会接受它作为事实。我不敢相信你称年龄相关的生育能力下降与性别无关。
Yeah. That's a bold claim. My bad. Okay. That's why I'm marrying a doctor, folks. We clarified it here. It's not gender agnostic. It's a bold claim. My bad. Okay. That's why I'm marrying a doctor, folks. We clarified it here. It's not gender agnostic. It's very, very different by sex.
是的。那是一个大胆的声明。我的错。好的。这就是为什么我娶了一位医生，各位。我们在这里澄清了。它不是与性别无关的。那是一个大胆的声明。我的错。好的。这就是为什么我娶了一位医生，各位。我们在这里澄清了。它不是与性别无关的。它在性别上是非常，非常不同的。
Okay. And I guess the main other thing I wanted to say was that you all had a really hyper focus on finish lines. Like I think you guys said marriage finish line, kids finish line. It's not a finish line. It's a process. So there's another conceptualization I felt that I had to correct or bring up. Wait, and lastly, I thought it was interesting that you were catastrophizing.
好的。我想我要说的另一件主要事情是，你们所有人对终点线都有非常高度的关注。就像我想你们说结婚终点线，孩子终点线。这不是终点线。这是一个过程。所以这是我感到必须纠正或提出的另一个概念化。等等，最后，我觉得有趣的是你在灾难化。
So you said things like, I'm going to be here alone for the rest of my life. What brought that on? You were only 31, Connor. So much of life ahead of you still is. I mean, you're not thinking like a statistician. In actuarial science, there's something called Bayesian credibility and credibility theory. It's a Bayesian estimation, but it's this idea that like you have a prior estimate of what the probability of something is. Maybe it's flipping a coin is like 50-50, which is a bad example because we know that actually is 50-50. But if it's some unknown event, like, you know, what's the probability that this person will get married, aka me? Maybe we think that's like 85%, you know, because I'm a catch. But as time goes on and it does not happen, you are informing the prior estimation with like it not happening.
所以你说了一些话，比如，我余生都要一个人在这里了。是什么导致了这一点？你才31岁，Connor。未来还有那么多生活等着你。我的意思是，你没有像统计学家那样思考。在精算科学中，有一种东西叫贝叶斯可信度和可信度理论。这是一个贝叶斯估计，但这个想法是，就像你对某件事的概率有一个先验估计。也许是抛硬币，就像50-50，这是一个糟糕的例子，因为我们知道那实际上是50-50。但如果是一些未知的事件，比如，你知道，这个人结婚的概率是多少，也就是我？也许我们认为那是85%，你知道，因为我是一个抢手货。但随着时间的推移，它没有发生，你正在用它没有发生来通知先验估计。
And therefore, like you keep on updating like, oh, the probability that he will get married is just going to decrease over time. The longer that that doesn't happen, the more and more you're updating your prior estimation of the probability of it happening. And it's just going down. Like, it's just statistics. It's not, I'm not saying it's hopeless. It's like I said, you know.
因此，就像你不断更新，就像，哦，他结婚的概率只会随着时间的推移而降低。它发生的时间越长，你对它发生的先验估计更新得就越多。它只是在下降。就像，这只是统计学。我不是说它是绝望的。就像我说的，你知道。
So all I hear is the initial cognitive distortion of a catastrophizing followed by the defense mechanism of rationalization. So I'm just going to say that you were catastrophizing. I'm not catastrophizing. This is statistics. I'm a link in the description or in the show notes, folks. I'll also put a link in for defense mechanism. You can't put a link in.
所以我听到的只是灾难化的初始认知扭曲，随后是合理化的防御机制。所以我只是要说你在灾难化。我没有灾难化。这是统计学。我是一个链接在描述中或节目笔记中，各位。我也会放一个关于防御机制的链接。你不能放链接。
I'm the one that puts the links in. You send me a link and I'll think about putting it in. Okay. And I guess then now getting on to what Bryce and Ramona said. So Bryce said it's a race to having children first. Just wanted to remind him there's no race. There's no end game, just a process. And he also commented on how he looks back at that podcast and was thinking how he's so young. And I was just thinking how in a couple of years he will look back on this podcast and think again that he was
我是那个放链接的人。你发给我一个链接，我会考虑放进去。好的。我想现在谈谈Bryce和Ramona所说的。所以Bryce说这是一场谁先有孩子的比赛。只是想提醒他没有比赛。没有终局，只有一个过程。他还评论了他是如何回顾那个播客并思考他是多么年轻。我只是在想，几年后他会再次回顾这个播客，并再次认为他当时
so young. So I hope that he recognizes that he's super young. And I guess that's it. Those are my main thoughts. So I just gave you all my thoughts. What do. And I guess that's it. Those are my main thoughts. So I just gave you all my thoughts. What do you have to say? What was it like for you to listen to that now? I love you. You're very smart. And that's why I'm marrying you.
是如此年轻。所以我希望他认识到他非常年轻。我想就是这样。这些是我的主要想法。所以我刚才给了你们我所有的想法。你有什么要说的？现在听那个是什么感觉？我爱你。你非常聪明。这就是我娶你的原因。
No, not to me. What was it like to listen to that old episode again? Oh. What was it like to listen to me two and a half years ago? Must have been pretty weird. I guess you're used to listening to yourself. I think it... He does a lot of talks, folks.
不，不是对我。再次听那个旧集是什么感觉？哦。再次听两年半前的我感觉如何？一定很奇怪。我想你习惯了听你自己。我想它……他做了很多演讲，各位。
He talks a lot, folks. I do have more podcasts than the average person. And a YouTube, quote underscore report. Yes. Check it out. I think that I literally a year ago had a plan to kind of start traveling the world and would not have predicted that I was going to meet you. And I think you heard that kind of in my voice from two and a half years ago.
他话很多，各位。我确实比一般人有更多的播客。还有一个YouTube，引号下划线报告。是的。去看看吧。我想我一年前确实有一个计划，开始环游世界，并且不会预测到我会遇见你。我想你在两年半前我的声音里听到了那种。
Utter despair. I wasn't giving up hope. But just like you date for a decade, a decade and a half. And I wouldn't say it was like an absolute tragedy. But like you're not meeting the person you want to spend the rest of your life with. And after like a decade or a decade and a half of that. Like I said, you're not giving up hope. But you're like, how long does it take? A know, a lot of my friends have already met that person
彻底的绝望。我并没有放弃希望。但就像你约会了十年，十年半。我不会说这就像一场绝对的悲剧。但就像你没有遇见你想共度余生的人。在经历了十年或十年半之后。就像我说的，你没有放弃希望。但你就像，这需要多久？你知道，我的很多朋友已经遇见了那个人
and got married and it just wasn't happening for me. And you, I think you heard that like in, you know, two and a half years ago, me, and I was kind of preparing to just like set up for a different life, you know, a life of traveling, working remotely, giving talks, being involved in the conference circuit. I get a lot of intrinsic value from meeting people, you know, different parts of the world that are just as excited about the technologies that I'm excited about or different technologies. It's just really cool to meet people. And I was preparing myself for that. And then out of the blue, I met you, fell in love. And yeah, so I just think it's a, you never know.
并且结婚了，而这并没有发生在我身上。而你，我想你在，你知道，两年半前，我身上听到了那个，我当时正准备去，就像，为另一种生活做准备，你知道，一种旅行、远程工作、做演讲、参与会议巡回的生活。我从遇见世界各地的人那里获得了很大的内在价值，你知道，他们和我一样对技术感到兴奋，或者对不同的技术感到兴奋。遇见人们真的很酷。我当时正在为自己做准备。然后突然之间，我遇见了你，坠入爱河。是的，所以我只是认为这是一个，你永远不知道。
Don't give up hope, folks. There you go. We met on the dating apps. Now you're on the right messaging. It is, I know it can be a, what's the word? A slog. Yeah, I don't know if I'd use slog. I'd use the words morally destructive, morally destroying process of like,
不要放弃希望，各位。给你。我们在约会软件上相遇。现在你在正确的轨道上。这是，我知道它可以是一个，什么词？苦差事。是的，我不知道我会不会用苦差事。我会用道德上具有破坏性的，道德上摧毁的过程，就像，
you do it for a month and it just makes you feel despair and hopelessness. But we are the success story. And we know a couple other folks that are success stories of the dating apps. Lots of folks. Everyone meets on an app now. You don't meet on an app. But in order to meet on an app, there is a lot of going on dates with folks that you don't click with necessarily. And maybe sometimes it can feel like it's it's i know this isn't a dating podcast
你做了一个月，它只会让你感到绝望和无助。但我们是成功的故事。而且我们知道其他几位也是约会软件成功故事的人。很多人。现在每个人都在软件上相遇。你不在软件上相遇。但在软件上相遇，需要和那些你未必合得来的人约会很多次。而且也许有时它会感觉，它，我知道这不是一个约会播客
it's not a dating podcast in general but episode 200 is mostly a dating and forecasting podcast so do you talk about tech at any point in this episode no i think literally the intro will be welcome to episode 200 of adsb the podcast feel free to skip this if you're only here for the tech content so then I will say that the only way you can make it through all that dating stuff is to think of it as an opportunity to go out explore hobbies meet people have fun you can't kind of think of it as all or nothing every time you're going on a date or you'll feel soul crushed perfect way to end it don't give up hope folks be sure to check these show notes either in your Think of it as all or nothing every time you're going on a date or you'll feel soul crushed. Perfect way to end it.
这通常不是一个约会播客，但第200集大部分时间都在聊约会和预测，所以你们这集里有聊到技术吗？没有，我觉得开场白大概就是欢迎收听ADSP播客第200集，如果你只对技术内容感兴趣，请随意跳过。我会说，应对所有这些约会话题的唯一方法，就是把它看作是一个出去探索爱好、结识朋友、享受乐趣的机会。你不能每次约会都把它看作是孤注一掷，否则你会感到心力交瘁。这是结束本集的完美方式，别放弃希望，伙计们。一定要查看这些节目笔记，无论是把它看作是孤注一掷，还是每次约会都感到心力交瘁。这是结束本集的完美方式。
Don't give up hope, folks. Be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSP the podcast dot com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a get up discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast. It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. Tune in next time for your new co-host, Ben Dean, either interviewing Sean Parent or just talking to Ben Dean. What do you mean me? Are you going to be there too? I'll be there, yeah. I just saw the tweet from Sean Parent saying that he appreciated our apology,
别放弃希望，伙计们。请务必在你的播客应用或ADSPthepodcast.com上查看节目笔记，获取我们今天提到的所有内容的链接，以及一个可以留下想法、评论和问题的GitHub讨论链接。感谢收听。希望你们喜欢，祝大家有愉快的一天。低质量，高产量。这就是我们播客的标语。那不是标语。我们的标语是充满信息碎片的混乱。下次请收听你的新联合主持人Ben Dean的节目，无论是采访Sean Parent还是只和Ben Dean聊天。你什么意思，我吗？你也会在那里吗？我会去的，是的。我刚看到Sean Parent发的推文，说他很感激我们的道歉，
and he was talking about the three different algorithms used for std rotate for random access, bidirectional, and forward iterators. It's going to be talked about, folks, either with Sean Parent or with Ben Dean or with both of them. Maybe we'll try to set up both. We've got a busy schedule coming up in the next three weeks, but we're going to try and get both of them on. How are you going to edit this?
他当时正在谈论用于std::rotate的三种不同算法，分别针对随机访问迭代器、双向迭代器和前向迭代器。这一定会聊到的，伙计们，要么是和Sean Parent聊，要么是和Ben Dean聊，或者两者都有。也许我们会尝试安排他们两个都来。未来三周我们的日程很满，但我们会尽量让他们两个都参加。你打算怎么剪辑这一段？
We're all over the place. What do you mean? That is, you're way more on topic than Bryce is. This will be easy to edit compared to him. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们聊得太散了。你什么意思？也就是说，你比Bryce更切题。比起他，这一集很容易剪辑。这一集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。